qué es lo primero que hace después de
lograr un acuerdo para comprar twitter
twittear sobre ello al menos eso fue lo
que hizo él en más que tras pactar el
lunes la adquisición del gigante de las
redes sociales por unos 44 mil millones
de dólares dirigiendo a la empresa hacia
la esfera privada calificando a twitter
como la plaza del pueblo digital más que
dijo que quiere mejorar la plataforma
añadiendo nuevas características ese va
principal en la mente del hombre más
rico del mundo es la libertad de
expresión más que lleva tiempo
criticando la moderación de contenidos
de twitter que considera ahoga la libre
expresión de los tuiteros actualmente la
red social prohíbe a los usuarios cuyos
tweets se consideran racistas o
despectivos pero más que quiere una
pausa en lugar de una prohibición total
avivando los temores de que cierto ex
presidente pueda volver a la plataforma
thompson acaba de decir hace diez
minutos que no quiere volver a twitter
no significa que quiere volver a twitter
sabe que hay 80 millones de seguidores
esperándole ximos que está realmente a
favor de la libertad de expresión no
puede simplemente no dejar volver a
trump eso es seguro al fasher donald
trump que ahora tiene su propia red
social ha dicho que es poco probable que
vuelva a twitter pero los planes demás
han tocado la fibra sensible de los
críticos incluso en la casa blanca
llevamos mucho tiempo hablando y el
presidente lleva mucho tiempo haciéndolo
sobre su preocupación por el poder de
las plataformas de medios sociales
incluyendo twitter y otros para difundir
la información errónea la desinformación
la necesidad de que estas plataformas
sean responsables el empresario también
ha insinuado que se centrará en los
ingresos por suscripción para reducir el
número de anuncios en el sitio una
propuesta arriesgada para una empresa
que ya está en dificultades y que no ha
obtenido beneficios al menos durante los
últimos dos años